parlons d'europe avec la maison de
l'europe des yvelines sur sensations
avec le soutien financier de l'union
européenne
bonjour moitié bonjour à toutes et à
tous et bienvenue dans parlant d'europe
une émission qui s'inscrit dans le cadre
de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe et de la grande consultation
citoyenne qui est actuellement en cours
et vous êtes d'ailleurs invité à donner
votre avis et à partager vos idées sur
la plateforme numérique futur du point
europa.eu thème de ce numéro les droits
lgbt dont l'union européenne mathis wii
sera quelques exemples avant les pays
bas sont le dernier pays le premier pays
excusez-moi avoir autorisé le mariage
homosexuel
le danemark a lui été le premier pays
européen et même au monde à accepter que
des couples homosexuels à adopter des
enfants
globalement on le verra les droits des
personnes lgbt continue d'avancer
même si 43% des personnes lgbt vivant
dans le new york 1 se sont sentis
discriminés au moins une fois dont les
douze dernières mois d'après l'agencé
européenne dans d'élus des droits
fondamentaux
cette émission se veut interactive elle
a été préparée à travers un atelier
radio par des collégiens des lycéens et
des étudiants des jeunes qui sont aussi
allés à votre rencontre vous le verrez
nos invités répondront aux questions que
vous vous posez
et puis nous relaierons aussi des
questions que vous nous avez posé sur
les réseaux sociaux dans un beat est
justement dans un instant eric nehr les
rues député autrichienne et président de
la commission des droits des femmes et
de l'égalité des genres ira tolérer les
réécouter française et membre suppléant
de la commission des droits des femmes
et de l'égalité des genres rebih
gastaldi président délégué de gaylib
mouvement libéral et humaniste associé à
mouvement radical pardon et cofondateur
de sgbt y libre sauf hureau et pour
commencer nous recevons olivier chanut
et jeanne ou excès responsable de robes
thérèse saint germain en laye bonjour
olivier jeunes excellent alors olivier
je vous propose d'écouter dans un
premier temps ce micro-trottoir raphaël
élèves du collège blaise pascal de
plaisir dans les yvelines est allez vous
demander si vous connaissez les droits
des personnes lgbt
on en parle tout de suite après est ce
que vous savez quels sont les droits
lgbt pour les
les lesbiennes les gays les bisexuels
transsexuels qu'est ce qui a changé pour
eux bah il ya plus de bain ils ont
mariage autorisé genre les homosexuels
et après non je crois
pareil je pense qu'il y en a eu mais
c'est un tout petit par rapport baptisé
a eu du coup les mariages des mariages
qui a été accepté dans beaucoup de pays
mais il ya encore des pays où c'est
interdit et aussi punie par la loi donc
pareil il ya eu des avancées mais ne
s'est pas des grandes grandes avancées
ça a commencé surtout en langue je pense
est donc démonstration que ce sont des
humains qui ont les mêmes droits et les
mêmes sens d'amour mais avec pour autre
personne que les ai trop par rapport à
d'autres fois on est plus tolérant de
nos jours se trouve est aussi choisi le
marais s'il a été autorisée aussi
légalisés après c'est tout ce que je
sais pas s'il ya eu en france surtout le
mariage entre autres membres je pense
que c'est un mariage et travers quand
même des enfants les droits lgbt ont été
en juin dernier au coeur d'un sommet
européen à bruxelles
que s'est il passé mathis alors le 15
juin dernier le parlement hongrois a
voté une loi interdisant la plus la
promotion de l'homosexualité ou du
changement de sexe auprès des mineurs
les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
réunis à bruxelles dans les jours qui
ont suivi ont dénoncé une politique
contraire aux valeurs de l'europe
le premier ministre néerlandais a même
sauvé le pays de respecter les droits
lgbt ou bien de quitter l'union olivier
jornot x depuis 1999 l'union européenne
a le pouvoir d'agir en cas de
discrimination fondée sur l'orientation
sexuelle différente espère dispositions
ont été adoptées par le traité
d'amsterdam n'est ce pas alors
effectivement et il faut bien comprendre
en fait l'apport que a fait le traité
d'amsterdam en la matière parce que le
traité d'amsterdam fait rentrer la
question de
de l'égalité notamment en matière du
moins l'égalité de traitement en matière
d'orientation sexuelle dans les traités
européens
donc grosso modo à partir de là ce qui
va se passer
alors c'est l'article c'est l'article 13
du sertic le 13 du du traité d'amsterdam
qui dit grosso modo le conseil statuera
l'unanimité sur proposition de la
commission
bla bla bla bla bla je passe une partie
de l'âge passe une partie de la
procédure législative donc le conseil
peut prendre les mesures nécessaires en
vue de combattre toute discrimination
fondée sur le sexe la race ou l'origine
ethnique la religion ou les convictions
un handicap l'âge ou l'orientation
sexuelle est en fait cet ajout permet
donc de va donc permettre à l'union
européenne de pouvoir agir concrètement
dans la question de l'égalité de
traitement en matière d'orientation
sexuelle et de pouvoir prendre des actes
juridiques afin de pouvoir créer des
droits garantir des droits protéger et
pour protéger notamment les minorités
lgbt et donc par exemple on a eu
notamment le cas où en fait on va avoir
l'union européenne qui va créer des
textes spécifiques et qui va aussi
modifier après d'autres textes par
exemple en matière de textes créés on a
une première directive qui est la
directive 2000 78e qui va en fait porté
sur la création d'un cadre général de
traitement en matière d'emploi et de
travail notamment pour les notamment
pour les personnes lgbt
en fait qui va avoir pour objectif en
fait de commencer à les inclure
du moins de forcer les états à
commencent à inclure les à créer des
stratégies positive pour pouvoir inclure
les lgbt dans les minorités lgbt donc
dans leurs législations nationales et
aussi par exemple en matière de deux
directives qui ont été modifiées on a
notamment par exemple une directive de
2006 sur la question de l'égalité de
traitement alors à la base qui était
pour l'égalité hommes femmes est en fait
c'est que cette directive
on va la modifier et en fait on va
élargir son champ d'application pour
pouvoir intégrer les minorités lgbt donc
déjà on élargit son champ d'application
concernant le public qui est concerné et
on va aussi élagir son champ
d'application son champ d'application
matériel ou en fait à la base cette
directive ne concernait que
spécifiquement la question de la
rémunération est là on va notamment
intégrer la question de l'égalité des
chances en matière d'accès à l'emploi
parlons d'europe vos questions la suite
de cette émission parlons d'europe à
présent
rémy gastellier président président
président part dans deux galeries et
cofondateur de lgbt est libre libre à
s'offrir pour répondre aux questions que
vous vous posez des questions relayées
par raphaël justin est mature scène des
élèves du collège blaise pascal de
plaisir dans les yvelines
dans quel pays européenne les
discriminations envers les personnes
lgbt sont elles fréquentes mais déjà il
faut savoir qu'il faut distinguer
l'union européenne du continent européen
au sein de l'union européenne nous avons
deux pros pays qui sont particulièrement
problématiques à savoir la pologne et la
hongrie
puisqu'on nous avons des gouvernements
qui sont partis comme en hd les
téléphones le gouvernement polonais va
inciter à discriminer ouvertement les
les personnes lgbt
sur l'ensemble du territoire et vont
inciter à déclarer certaines certains
territoires comme zone antilles lgbt
ce qui est un non sens et ce qui est
totalement illégal surtout en regard du
droit européen en termes de la
protection des minorités
quant à la hongrie qui vient de
de proclamer en fait l'interdiction de
la publicité pour les valeurs
homosexuels selon ce qui a été
retranscrit l'appareil nous sommes dans
une purée gay l'égalité il ne plus
enfreindre du droit européen est tout
simplement de la dignité humaine
ensuite il y a des problèmes dans le
reste du continent européen
nous avons les ong europe qui chaque
année nous propose une carte en fait
avec les pirelli en fait avant un
classement fait des pays en termes de
progrès des droits lgbt et nous on peut
voir que chaque année la turquie
l'azerbaïdjan le la russie naturellement
le bélarus sont des pays où le simple
fait d'être soupçonnée d'être une
personnes lgbt y est signée peut
signifier dans une mort ce tout
simplement les sanctions envers les pays
européens où les personnes lgbt sont
victimes des discriminations sont elles
suffisantes
nous avons tout l'arsenal qu'il faut il
maintenant il sait du poids du courage
politique dont nous avons besoin
en réalité les moyens d'action sur les
pays membres de l'union européenne
c'est tout simplement ce sont des cette
sanction financière non pas en termes
d'amande
mais par exemple en termes de d'exiger
le simplement que la condition
l'attribution des aides européennes
soient soient conditionnées donc à au
strict respect du tout la dignité
humaine et de toutes les minorités
sachant que le la hongrie et la pologne
sont des très grands large bénéficiaires
des aides européennes
ce serait un moyen efficace pour les
inciter à stopper purement et simplement
toutes ces discriminations
sachant que nous avons des pays qu'ils
soient un internat millions au lieu
européenne où qu'il soit candidat ni
robben qui ont compris très rapidement
que c'était largement leur défaveur
principalement pour ses sanctions
financières ou ses options en termes
dead 2
d'arrêter en fait toute discrimination
d'ordre national ou même territoriale en
vis-à-vis des personnes âgées bti mais
cela va de même pour n'importe quelle
minorité qu'elle soit religieuse ou
ethnique par exemple pas les mêmes
droits
et bien en fait c'est comme ça que le
droit européen construit lui on parle
d'une construction européenne et nous
avons construit une union européenne
petit à petit d'abord sur l'économie
pour avoir une union plus politique
depuis 1992
donc aujourd'hui il est tout à fait
compatible avec le droit européen de ne
pas avoir de mariage homosexuel
d'adoption homosexuels etc
en revanche porté atteinte directement
hall à l'intégrité physique des
personnes vaidéhi ça c'est parfaitement
interdit par par l'union européenne donc
aujourd'hui nous allons avoir certaines
situations qui vont du qui vont de la
production totale des personnes adjectif
à l'absence totale sans aller dans une
répartition est ou ouest un peu trop
traditionnel on peut voir que rien que
même dans les pays occidentaux que deux
pays en l'occurrence l'italie la grèce
n'ont pas de mariage non pas d'adoption
pour les couples de même sexe alors que
tous les autres pays de l'ex europe de
l'ouest ont le mariage et l'adoption
vous allez avoir des pays qui sont qui
ont adopté une union civile à l'est nous
avons des pays qui sont vont être
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus tolérants
envers les personnes trans par exemple
et des pays qui ne qui ne sont pas tous
à du moment que nous il n'y a pas de
destination encourager et systématique
cette incompatibilité avec le droit
européen hélas et c'est ce qu'il faut
changer
il faut ouvrir itab le mans que l'on
puisse avoir le même droit dans toute
l'union européenne
c'est ce qu'a reconnu la cour européenne
de justice notamment dans le cas du
mariage homosexuel puisque si vous êtes
mariés dans un état vous avez vous êtes
censé avoir la même protection dans un
autre état donc mais vous ne pouvez pas
vous marier dans un état où le mariage
homosexuel est interdit par exemple
quels sont les pays européens les plus
gay friendly
oui les personnes lgbt ont le plus de
droits donc il faut d'abord définir
quels
les critères qui font qu'une un pays
greffe et gay friendly savez d'abord le
mariage et l'adoption pour les couples
de même sexe afin de faire famille ça va
être pour les personnes trans la
facilité à changer son état civil et le
remboursement des des opérations
chirurgicales
ils le traitent et il a le traitement
hormonal ça va être pour les personnes
intersexe l'interdiction des mutilations
génitales dès la naissance ou pour les
enfants pas deux en âge de consentir du
coup vous allez avoir des pays où le
débat est très explicite est très avancé
donc par exemple vous allez voir des
pays comme l'allemagne qui il va y avoir
un débat sur
est-ce que nous avons besoin d'un
troisième sexe sur les pieds et sur les
sur nos papiers d'identité ou une
absence de l'absence de cette mention
sur nos papilles des entités donc on
peut pas dire qu'il y à un pays plus gay
friendly que l'autre on va parler d'une
en termes de honte parce qu'il faut
prendre la totalité des critères les
donc il faut voir le droit mais il faut
voir aussi la société vous avez vous
allez avoir des pays où il est
parfaitement normal d'être un homme ou
une femme politique
lg pays et même de diriger pays
actuellement vous avez le luxembourg qui
est dirigée par un homme ouvertement
homosexuel tout comme la belgique il
était il ya encore quelques années et
l'islande par une part sa première
ministre il ya quelques années encore
vous avez toujours sur la belgique
un signal d'ouverture extraordinaire
avec la première ministre ans petra de
suter qui est une ancienne députée
européenne verte et pourquoi on peut
qualifier la belgique de pays
particulièrement élevé elle était
friendly c'est tout simplement parce que
quand peut-être à 18 heures a été nommé
ministre
on peut pas dire qu'il ait eu une
position particulière et on peut même
dire que tout le monde s'en fiche et non
pas pour des raisons politiques mais
parce que c'est parfaitement normal
là où en france on a eu pour la première
fois une mère ouvertement transgenres
qui était élu en 2009 nous avons eu des
beaucoup d'un beaucoup de retours
positifs
c'était quand même une surprise c'est le
moment où l'inclusion des personnes lgbt
dans la société est parfaitement commun
que vous allez avoir un état voire
parfaitement lgbt freiner
donc vous pouvez naturellement cité la
suède les pays scandinaves signe parce
qu'ils aiment en pointe sur ces sujets
là une nouvelle série de questions
réponses à présent withera c'est au tour
maintenant d'evelyne raygner
l'eurodéputé autrichienne et président
de la commission des droits des femmes
et de l'égalité des genres et de irène
tolérer l'eurodéputée française qui est
membre suppléant de la commission des
droits des femmes et de l'égalité des
genres pourquoi des couples gays
d'adopter d'un certain pays de l'eu et
pas dans d'autres
des évolutions sont elles prévues ça
c'est une question à des législations
nationales et donc au niveau européen
nous avons les articles 2 et 3 du traité
de l'union européenne où le principe les
principes de non discrimination sont
vraiment des valeurs européen et donc on
peut faire quelque chose sur les
principes en général au niveau européen
mais malheureusement pas en ce qui
concerne les détails et donc il y a
beaucoup de législations différentes
dans les pays acp en europe
alors d'abord il faut savoir que comme
je voulais dit tout à l'heure nous avons
notre première commissaire à l'égalité
qui vient de malte qui est très le pays
le plus en avance de notre union sur le
droits des lgbt et donc pour la première
fois de l'histoire de notre union nous
avons une stratégie en faveur des
membres d'eelv était cuit et notamment
qui pose la question du droit des
familles homoparentales pour être
extrêmement clair on peut pas dans le
même temps avoir un marché unique avoir
erasmus et dire à tous les européens
allaient on est uni dans notre diversité
et tout le monde peut circuler et dans
le même temps avoir une définition
familial qui est différente
ça veut dire que concrètement en ce
moment dans notre union on peut avoir
des parents hétérosexuels ou de même
sexe qui ont des enfants qui l'ont
adopté et qui dans un pays de notre
union si cet enfant a un problème de
maladie à l'école ne vont pas avoir les
mêmes droits par rapport à la gestion de
la maladie ou de l'accident de leur
enfant c'est absolument inadmissible et
justement dans cette stratégie pour
les lgbt cuit stratégie européenne la
commissaire a posé le principe d'un
texte législatif majeur qui dit que
quand on est parent dans un pays de
notre union on est parent dans tous les
pays de notre union c'est très important
pourquoi le mariage homosexuel n'est pas
reconnue dans tous les pays de l'union
européenne
est ce que cela peut changer si oui
comment
ah ça peut changer parce que il y a des
bons exemples
voilà en belgique on voit ça fonctionne
bien
en autriche on voit ça fonctionne bien
donc ça c'est une sorte positif
publicité voilà ça c'est ce sont des
exemples on doit s'y suivre et on voit
ça marche bien donc j'espère qu'on peut
inspirer les autres pays en europe de
faire la même chose alors ja
deux sujets au travers du mot mariage
donc le mot mariage est un mot qui peut
avoir une connotation religieuse
en revanche le fait que un couple se
forme et est exactement les mêmes droits
face à l'impôt face à la famille face à
l'héritage face au droit du travail est
essentiel pour l'égalité dans notre
union et du coup dans un certain nombre
de pays nous avons des ce que l'on
appelle le mariage pour tous mais en
fait un contrat exactement comme un
mariage qui a été mis en place pour que
les familles lgbt cuit qui souhaitent
officialiser est exactement les mêmes
droits que des familles hétérosexuelles
qui officialise en revanche ce n'est pas
encore le cas dans tous les pays de
notre union c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut vraiment faire avancer mais il faut
faire avancer en sachant que un des
freins c'est la religion c'est pour ça
que j'ai dit mariage et peut-être pas le
bon mot sur le texte
même si à la fin quand il s'agira de
faire la fête avec les copains ça sera
la même
pourquoi les droits parentaux des
couples homosexuels ne sont ils pas tous
les mêmes dans tous les pays européens
que peut faire l'europe ben on a
culturellement on part deux points très
différents
nous avons des pays qui ont rejoint
notre union il ya moins longtemps et qui
sont sortis du bloc soviétique être un
pays qui était dans le bloc soviétique
c'était être un pays où il était
complètement interdit d'aller à l'église
il n'y a rien qui donne plus envie de
faire quelque chose que ce soit
complètement interdit donc depuis qu'ils
sont sortis du bloc soviétique ils se
précipitent tous vers le fait religieux
et se fait religieux est contradictoire
avec la reconnaissance de
l'homosexualité ou la transsexualité ou
tout simplement la sensibilité au genre
voilà donc il faut bien se dire qu'on a
des points de départ qui sont différents
et donc il faut à tout prix sortir du
fait religieux et venir dans le vrai
sujet qui est d'abord la liberté qui est
une des valeurs fondamentales de notre
union et puis aussi la reconnaissance du
fait que certains sujets peuvent être
des sujets qui sont liées à la santé et
non pas aux droits fondamentaux et ce
qui est important c'est que un
transgenre en conversion qui a besoin de
son traitement hormonal et ben ce
traitement il est aussi important que
une femme qui prend la pilule
il n'y a pas un qui est moins ou plus
qui offre plus ou moins de droits que
l'autre c'est la liberté des européens
de pouvoir maîtriser leur corps et de
vivre leur vie comme ils l'entendent
donc c'est important qu'on des bugs en
disant c'est pas on n'est pas en train
d'essayer d'avoir un monde où est ultra
libérale qui viendraient contrer un
monde est ultra catho on est juste en
train de dire que tous unis en tant
qu'européen
on doit pouvoir accès aux mêmes droits à
la santé les personnes lgbt sont dans
certains pays deux lieux victimes de
discrimination existe-t-il des moyens de
pression contre ces pays pour lutter
contre la haine envers les personnes
lgbt
oui ça c'est vraiment un grand grand
grand problème surtout en pologne
et il y a des moyens il s'agit des
valeurs de principes de l'union européen
de respecter tout le monde et voilà ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire plus de
d'argent d'europe pour ces pays là parce
que il s'agit des trois fondamentaux et
changistes et tout le parlement européen
insiste que la commission européenne a
une obligation de défense
les droits fondamentaux de la communauté
lgbt ique donc de faire des mesures et
sinon on va à aller devant à la cour de
justice
en europe c'est à dire c'est une
obligation européenne et non les
parlementaires d'europe ont ainsi ce de
faire quelque chose donc plus d'argent
pour les pays comme la pologne
quand ils ne respectent pas les droits à
dungey tvq
l'union européenne est devenue une zone
de liberté pour les personnes lgbt
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que cela signifie
alors la déclaration cette résolution
c'est une déclaration symbolique alors
j'entends des gens qui disent ouais les
symboles c'est facile il ya que ceux qui
croient qu'ils sont contents oui mais
derrière un symbole
il ya des actions est par exemple une
derrière l'union européenne qui s'est
déclarée comme zone de liberté pour les
lgbt cuit nous avons un certain nombre
de collectivités territoriales qui
commence à faire exactement la même
chose
et derrière qui peuvent aligner des
budgets pour lutter contre la répression
dont encore dans notre union
les membres de la communauté lgbt cuit
peuvent
subir ça peut être des choses très
tendue dans des pays où il ya une
volonté politique de leur nuire il ya du
harcèlement il ya des jeunes qui
quittent la pologne
voilà qui se sentent très très mal dans
leur pays mais ça peut aussi être le cas
en france pendant le confinement
nous avons des jeunes qui ont été mis à
la rue par leurs parents puisque le
confinement a donné l'occasion à leurs
parents de découvrir que leur enfant
était gai et qu'ils les ont mis dehors
en plein confinement donc c'est
important que être une collectivité
territoriale qui se délibère pour dire
qu' elle aussi est les zones de liberté
pour les lgbt cuits à la collectivité
territoriale elle a des budgets qu'elle
peut aligner pour en gros à voir ddd
refuge
justement pour accueillir les jeunes qui
seraient victimes
de violence ou jetés à la rue par leurs
familles ou leurs proches fort mais
aussi les forces de police puisque face
aux violences homophobes
quand un jeune vient porter plainte à la
gendarmerie ou à la police
nous avons un déficit de formation et
donc le fait de porter plainte peut être
très douloureux donc à voir ce que l'on
appelle des rainbow desk dans toutes les
gendarmeries ou les polices pour que les
jeunes puissent porter plainte ou pas
les plus jeunes ou 20 ceux qui sont
subis qui subissent des violences
homophobes
on peut aussi bien entendu puisque c'est
une compétence des régions ont travaillé
sur les lycées ou des départements
travailler sur les collèges pour que y
ait des des discussions avec soin des
gens issus des refuges soit des jeunes
migrants qui ont quitté un pays parce
qu'ils risquaient la peine de mort parce
qu'ils étaient membres de l'ag
communauté le gp tic lui ai donc avoir
une sensibilité au genre auprès des plus
jeunes dans leur lieu de formation
toutes ces choses là peuvent être
financés par les collectivités
territoriales qui se déclarent zone de
liberté pour l'egypte qui cuit donc on
voit qu'un symbole européen peut devenir
une politique très concrète localement
pour tout le monde voilà vous en savez
un peu plus maintenant sur ce que fait
l'europe pour lutter contre la haine et
les discriminations anti lgbt
merci encore une fois à justin mature
sané raphaël du collège blaise pascal de
plaisir dans les yvelines d'avoir relayé
les questions que vous nous avez posé
sur les réseaux sociaux
et puis vous le savez une grande
consultation sienne est en cours
jusqu'au premier semestre 2022 vous êtes
invités à vous exprimer et à imaginer
l'europe de demain on vous rappelle
l'adresse de la plateforme numérique
futur e au point et repas point
plateformes mises en place à l'occasion
de la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe
vous pourrez ainsi partager vos idées
sur différents thèmes changements
climatiques sont et justice sociale et
emploi démocraties européennes
transformation numérique etc et non
merci mathis parlant d'europe s'est
terminée merci à l'équipe pour avoir
préparé cette émission on se retrouve
bientôt merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous merci sarah on espère avoir répondu
aux principales questions que vous vous
posez
et n'oubliez pas de prolonger le débat
sur nos réseaux sociaux c'était parlant
d'europe sur sensations plus d'infos sur
maison europe 78e